ambulance uh as jake knows whenever i
interview him i have to bring up
something um and it's called zodiac and
i was trying to figure out a new way to
tie zodiac into ambulance and i think i
got it um wow can you compare a little
bit because
bay and fincher are so radically
different similar very similar exactly
in fact let me yeah they're so similar
in the way that they work with the
amount of takes and the slowness to the
speed uh can you sort of compare and
contrast bay and venture
in tech in technic technique however you
would like to do it
that
good luck um
well actually i would say
um
you know you're talking about two
auteurs right i mean that's what i i
don't think people would necessarily
consider
michael bay to be that but in in
or or he wouldn't be deemed that you
know but i i do i you know in in the
action genre i think he's an auteur and
his style in working
is about capturing what is alive and
real
in in in a moment and i think outside of
fincher and and comparatively uh
bay i think every great director that
i've worked with
has is going after what is honest
they're great because that's what
they're trying to do whether it's in the
frame which i know fincher spends a lot
of time focused on but michael does too
in a totally different way they're
actually
they're actually radically similar
in
them following energy that they feel is
honest
uh i am a big fan of michael bay and he
and i agree with what you're saying um
he's such a unique filmmaker because he
pivots in the moment into whatever he
sees
and i'm curious for all three of you
what is it like to work with someone who
will be like okay let's just go on the
highway right now and we're going to
film this and i need you to learn these
lines and go i think it's really
artistic yes i mean i know that sounds
kind of like it's sort of not this but
it felt really artistic totally
absolutely it was like this is a whim
i'm gonna go over here let's go and
because you gotta jump on it yeah yeah
yeah got you got to be game and just
stop asking questions you know just stop
asking questions
and just say okay this is how this like
after after about two days
you get to sort of understand oh this is
how this movie works so this is how
making this movie works because it was
different for me you know it was for
sure for sure different for me like a
director who
improvises
you know most of the directors that i've
had it's all been storyboarded and
planned and planned out and you have a
little bit of a little bit of
delineation from like the things that we
plan to do
a little bit but michael is really you
know he has the plan and then he's
working from inspiration at the same
time yeah and there was days that we
were i mean as an actor is sort of a
great gift you know sometimes you
you become comfortable with um
this rhythm of you know what you're
going to shoot in which and wit in each
day and sort of you build slowly to that
and i think that we we learned really
quickly on day two or three that
basically there was days that he would
pull up and he's like we're gonna do
scene 45 of the and we're like wait
that's slated for three weeks he's like
i don't know i gotta shoot it right now
because i have an idea and just came
into my mind you gotta do so as an actor
you're sort of over prepared and
advanced now and now not him but us we
were of course he's never prepared but
um and then you really are just like
[ __ ] it let's go like let's do whatever
we got here
sorry
jesus open this kind of word
i'm very sorry i refuse to anyway
yeah uh the surgery scene in the
ambulance in this film is a
i almost cursed but i pulled myself back
um it is effing crazy they actually you
i'm not in that scene but they used my
spleen
it was his
yeah he donated just so you know i sort
of yeah on that scene but like i'm not
given the credit that i deserve yeah
jake did it for the love of art
i didn't know you know this is very
interesting that this is the movie you
were willing to donate this
isn't it yes it is of all the movies it
was this one
um but i am curious what was it like
actually filming that sequence because
it's such a nail biter i had to look
away from the screen a little bit i had
to look away from the job a little bit
i wanted to look away and i couldn't
yeah yeah it was i mean what was that
like for you
i mean for both of us it was it was um
yeah i mean you don't really know how to
play something like that at the moment
right it's like do i go overboard do i
just it's just like more more blood more
it's like i don't understand what's
happened like it was it was such a
strange
film uh scene to film because also he
just started adding things like when he
wakes up and you punch him
well that was added
on the script and he was just like
punching him and we're like wait what
he's like just letting him wake up i was
like
what and your hand's gonna be in his
stomach and at that point you're just
like let's go um but it was cool i mean
it's an incredible it's my one of my
favorite scenes that i've ever done it's
just it looks so real because of the way
he shoots it he just and and i think one
really cool thing that i've noticed that
happens in this movie looking back at
his uh work before is because of the
contained space that we had within the
ambulance it kind of forced him to
change a little bit the way he shoots in
his shots usually he's very
open with his shots and he's so close in
our faces in this movie because there's
no actual space for him to do it that it
gives so much um
the scene so much anxiety and it adds
like this vibrating handheld shots that
it really built that scene um more than
we it felt on the day but it was fun
we had so much fun and it was a good
you know we were throwing around things
and just doing wild
i will say what i was just i was upset
about was that i heard heard a lot about
the bullhorn
the michael bay bullhorn
oh that yeah
just never really we didn't have it yeah
you so you never because i've been on
set um watching him work and i've seen a
him moment where he got really upset
yeah yeah and then but i've also seen
him be the closest to the explosions
with his own camera holding it to make
sure the shot is perfect yes you know
yes there is amazing quality to him in
that i remember there were like four or
five shots where he said up that's in
the trailer
yeah shoot he'd be shooting it and he'd
go that's in the trailer it's in the
trailer you're like i'm trying to say
lie
can you just you know you're going oh
i'm acting and then it's like that's in
the trailer and he's like i'm like oh
dude you know mike i'm not thinking
about the trailer right sure enough
sure enough a number of those shots are
in the trailer yeah speaking of cool
shots this movie has shots that i've
never seen in any film because of the
drones and i'm curious what was it like
as actors how often were you you know
talk a little bit about the drones and
what was your reaction when you saw what
he was doing and and the guys with the
visual glasses and everything so that
the guys with the visual glasses are
like 14 years old it's incredible i mean
truly it's incredible the stuff they're
doing i mean they're drone racers i mean
essentially like
they're they're they're racing those
drones and then now they've you know
transposed that into filming it you know
but i mean some of those shots down the
buildings on the sides of the buildings
under the cars when they're jumping and
then also i'd never worked at drones
inside you know a lot of the heist is
drone work
flying by you you know as you're running
out with a with you know i mean there's
three shots in a very small small
quarters where they're actually drones
and the first shot that i did was in the
bank was a drone coming at me
and then them just saying to me like as
soon as it gets close enough you know
you should really they'll get out of
your way but you should probably too you
know and so you know
we we said we rolled and action and then
it sort of started coming to me it was
about a thousand yards away and i just
dropped
[Laughter]
so yeah that was courageous
yeah it was it was crazy it's just it's
cool you know i mean that doesn't really
do it do it justice if you say what is
it like it's really cool you know says
there's moments on this film where you
know where you can
if you haven't seen these if you haven't
seen
it done before you can you you you can
definitely lose a take watching the show
you know like watching the movie being
made you know because there's some
there's a lot of just really cool
moments um in the making of it and the
moment
just like like their eyes but they're
just sort of wandering who are 14 years
old
which is impressive they're so young you
walk in and they're like huh
and with the like little cops and we're
like who are these kids and they're like
oh they're the cameraman i'm like huh
and they're just like in there
like paid off to play all those video
games when they're growing up and
they're i mean future massive filmmakers
they're so good the shots are incredible
yeah and michael doesn't have an ego
he's he's like following the experts
yeah that's just another example of you
know the way that it works on that note
i need to stop i'm just going to say
congrats on the movie thank you and uh
hope to you know thanks for everything
you